vous remarquerez qu'il n'aura pas fallu
3 jours au gouvernement dans cette
rentrée parlementaire pour d'ors et déjà
dégainer le 493 la première ministre
ouvre donc la saison des 493
autoritaires nous la nuè de notre côté
ouvrons notre saison de la censure
populaire en déposant en tant que nupes
une motion de censure immédiatement ce
soir suite à ce 493 ce 493 il n'arrive
pas sur n'importe quel texte nous sommes
sur un texte de programmation des
finances public qui donne une
orientation budgétaire et cette
orientation budgétaire est la pire que
qui a jamais été faite dans notre pays
puisque on parle de 70 milliards
d'économie sur le dos des Français et
des françaises d'ici à 2027 la macronie
a été bien aidé dans cette opération par
le rassemblement national qui décidément
est l'assurance vie du système puisque
le rassemblement national s'est abstenu
en commission sur les 70 milliards
d'économies avec un texte qui avait
d'ors et déjà été rejeté par l'Assemblée
nationale en automne 2022 et qui va donc
continuer pour les Français et les
Françaises une maltraitance sociale et
écologique que nous ne pouvons pas
accepter et c'est pourquoi nous irons
dans les prochains jours à la censure du
gouvernement est-ce qu'on est surpris
pas vraiment on a un gouvernement qui
est 493 dépendant totalement addicte aux
violences faites au Parlement ça
commencé il y a un an ça continue et
nous craignons que ça continue encore
encore longtemps nous sommes dans notre
bon droit défend les Françaises et les
Français le gouvernement à travers ses
ministres comme sa majorité nous a
répété de façon continue qu'il avait
besoin de la confiance des marchés bah
nous on préfère la confiance des
Français des Français qui n'ont que leur
travail pour vivre et dont le
gouvernement a programmé sur de longues
années qu'il feraiit les poches à
travers une réduction de leurs droits
sociaux plutôt que d'aller chercher la
solidarité où elle peut être là où elle
peut être sollicité c'est-à-dire dans
les poches des grands groupes et des
grandes fortunes et bien rien ne change
avec ce gouvernement de quelques-uns et
bien nous serons les députés de tous les
aut